today is women's entrepreneurship day an
opportunity to shed light on women who
run their companies and who are taking
pretty big risks and that's a growing
number of entrepreneurs in the u.s about
20 percent of companies or 1.2 million
are owned by women in the u.s right now
that's according to census data among
them is one women one woman who upended
her career path to follow her passion
and create a new market for women
consumers excited about the tequila
space and i'm really excited to have
mara smith founder of inspiro tequila
joining us now from chicago uh mara
thank you so much for being here so have
to ask you first about what has your
entrepreneurship journey been like and
spiro is only a few months old on the
market so so what's it been like for you
to get it out there
yes well it's been it's been 20 months
in the making to get it to that point um
because there's a lot of planning that's
involved and an entire production
process that has to happen in mexico to
get it to that point so um it's been
really exciting with obviously lots of
ups and downs and like us we are dealing
with the major supply chain issues that
so many people are managing right now
but
a really exciting and and great uh
learning process for me because this is
my first entrepreneurial journey yeah
and mara i want to get to the supply
chain issues just in a minute but you
went from being a lawyer to then diving
into the tequila industry why make that
pivot
so
i practiced law for a number of years i
also worked in corporate strategy after
that at a fortune 100 company which i
think kind of sparked a little more of
my entrepreneurial spirit
because we were focused on looking at
consumer insights and trends and coming
up with new ideas
and after that i actually have been home
raising children for a number of years
but
the entrepreneurial journey and process
has always really intrigued me i
always found it fascinating how people
start something from scratch and bring
it to fruition so i knew i was always
going to start my own company
i guess why why tequila but um
that's because i became a tequila
drinker years ago i was looking for a
gluten-free clean spirit and i kept
searching for a brand that was additive
free and that had a look taste and aroma
that appealed to me
i didn't find one so i decided to start
in spiro tequila i also thought there
was there was room for innovation
and a female perspective in the spirits
industry can you expand on that because
tequila specifically has really been
dominated by men and we're seeing a lot
of celebrities get involved with their
own uh tequila brands um what what is
that reimagination that you were looking
there are a few things the
one of the things was that i really
wanted to create something that's
additive free so you may not know but a
lot of tequila brands that we we really
like have additives so i want to see if
i could create the taste
profiles um that people enjoy without
using additives that was the first part
i also
wanted to bring a female perspective
recognizing that there are not very many
women
owned and operated and created teal
brands so it was important to me that
women are involved in every part of the
process from our
famous female master distiller creating
the taste profiles to the women
responsible for getting it on the
shelves
and i think frankly we also came up with
a unique product offering uh i really
wanted a battle that stood out on the
shelves so we that was the first thing i
did was to create this really sleek and
sophisticated bottle that's easy to hold
and pour
it's 100
agave tequila
it's an ultra premium tequila that's
handcrafted in jalisco mexico
and we we created this really smooth and
simple blanco tequila so i think there's
a number of
ways that we differentiate ourselves
well and you mentioned some of the
issues that you've run into mara supply
chain uh we're also dealing with
inflation
how specifically have has that affected
your business and also your own journey
uh to get your brand on the market
supply chain has been a major factor our
battles come from overseas and have to
get to mexico so things to come from
china and that production the glass
shortage um
we've been due to receive battles for
like a month and a half right now and
they're still not there
so
there's the issue of our raw materials
and then the issue of actually
production and
um
getting that done in mexico and freight
i mean shipping is just astronomical and
that has a very major impact on a small
new brand
when
the the shipping costs are so
extraordinary what does that look like
mara i mean what does that major impact
look like and do you have to pass that
then down to the consumer
well we're trying to
i think we're trying to kind of take as
much as
that increased cost on ourselves as
possible
so we know that there are certain price
points that consumers want to be at when
they're they're looking for
you know tequila ultra premium tequilas
and especially to actually take the
chance and try a new brand
so
i think we're hoping that in the future
we'll be able to get those costs down
especially when we're maybe doing
more significant shipments um
and then
we can kind of make up for that at that
point but right now i'd say
we're pretty much taking most of the hit
on that
and mara i mean i think this is so
fascinating that you've been able to do
this considering this time
but we're also talking at a time when a
lot of people too are are wanting to
change jobs they're wanting to move
their careers um you know do something
different you did that um
what piece of advice would you give
people who are considering that right
now who want to make the pivot that you
made is now the right time to do it i
mean what are the questions that people
need to be asking themselves
uh i think so and i think the message
also for me is that it's never really
too late to pivot or to start something
on your own or enter a new industry
i guess my advice is that you have to do
the research you just really have to
educate yourself but there are so many
resources out there now that are
available to us right there are webinars
and podcasts and books and people that
follow on linkedin that have you know
great tips
so
really kind of there's a way to get
yourself up to speed pretty quickly in a
new industry
i also think you have to tap into
networks i've been really fortunate to
connect with just amazing communities of
female founders and leaders who have
just offered such incredible guidance
and been
willing to give me feedback
so
i think you really can't do it alone and
you need to to find those networks of
people who are there to collaborate and
support other
female founders and have you found that
a lot of your consumers too are you know
they care about the story behind the
brand because we are also seeing a lot
of consumers make that a priority too
how they're buying i wonder how you've
seen that
especially because there's such a story
behind yours
yes and
i did this from my perspective i am a
mindful consumer i'm thoughtful about
what i eat and drink which is why i
chose tequila as my drink of choice and
i'm thoughtful about the companies that
i purchase from so i think there are a
lot of other consumers out there who
feel the same way and want to hear the
story about it and want to know that
it's an authentic story
i think when people
see sometimes when i'm posting things
and showing that it's it's truly me
sitting on the floor of my dining room
packing up boxes
you can see
that
this is the you know authentic real
deal that's happening and it's not me
kind of putting just my name
um on a bottle that i'm involved in
every part of the process i think people
people want to know that there's an
authentic story behind it
absolutely mara smith ceo of inspiro
tequila thank you so much for being here
thanks so much for sharing your story
really appreciate your time